it's it's all based on what tyler
lockett thinks it's all based on what
tyler lockett thinks
joining us here on behalf of old spice
from the seattle seahawks back here on
the rich eyes and show tyler lockett how
are you tyler
you're pretty good how about yourself
well i mean you probably didn't think
i'd ask you this question do you think i
should get fake hair what do you think
i think you should just keep it natural
thank you tyler
i need to be true to who i am right
right you know what i'm saying
yeah well it's coming from a guy who's
trying to hold on before he has to go
bald too
now hold on a second uh the phrase hold
on um
you know definitely is infused with
something you just told me i'm
i i should stick on stick stick with
what i've got so i'm hanging on for dear
life
it's essentially what you're saying yeah
well i'm in the same boat as you
okay well you know interesting you are
coming on about um
uh with old spice talking about a
10-year initiative to help
young guys feel confident in their own
skin so i guess
it's interesting how i'm kind of having
a little bit of fun but there is a
subject matter that's uh somewhat
serious why did you decide to
hook up on this front tyler well
honestly i thought that it would be a
great idea just to be able to partner
with old spice just because it's all
about
being able to help kids thrive
especially in the days that we're living
in right now and
they chose to be able to do that
throughout the educational environment
and so just by being able to talk with
them and understanding like what it is
that they're trying to do
all the things that they're trying to
promote they came up with this 10-year
commitment plan
to increase high school graduation rates
just for young guys
and i think that's really big especially
in the black communities just with
everything that's going on
uh the way that we grow up those things
that we go through
a lot of times a lot of people drop out
of school and just to be able to be
committed to help people
to stay in school and be committed to to
increase the graduation rates
i think it says a lot and just
understanding how they decided to
partner and and to be able to work with
the
the film black boys that's also
something that i'm also looking forward
to being able to talk to so we can
continually
extend the conversation as we talk about
what's going on even
in america today yeah we spoke about
that documentary with malcolm jenkins
when he was on this show
uh just last week and that documentary
is available right here
on peacock um which is where you and i
tyler lockett and i are having this
conversation um
so uh were you not comfortable in your
own skin
as a younger man tyler
well i think i think when i grew up i
was comfortable in my own skin but it
was because i was around
people that looked like me you know my
whole entire life
and just how i grew up so i've always i
was always around
people in that aspect but as you get
away from
your family and your friends and people
who protect you you do start to see the
other side of life
and a lot of times you think especially
growing up that you don't have to deal
with racism because maybe it's just
because of where you grew up
at or where you were at at that time but
you realize that
even when you come to the nfl like it
doesn't change it's just
you you reach a different peak a
different level in your life and now
you're just hearing it from people that
are that never had to grow up in your
hometown so
you know there was times where i did go
to
um i was in bel air actually and it was
for one of my friends he was having a
bachelor party
and i had ran inside and a lot of them
was outside and we were about to leave
and get into uber
and it was a lady who came down the hill
who basically told everybody when i had
went inside
that we didn't belong up there and that
we didn't know how things worked up
there on the hill and stuff like that
and just how she was gonna call the cops
and you know she didn't know i was in
the nfl she didn't know i had money
she didn't know i could have bought a
house out there in beverly hill in bel
air
to even stay there or to even run out of
airbnb there but it's just the fact of
sometimes being in the color of our skin
we're just looked at differently like
we can't afford things or we don't
deserve to be up there or we don't even
know how
how the rules apply up there and so yeah
there is a lot of times where you end up
being put in situations or you see
things that you might have not been able
to peep as you were growing
up just because of who you were always
around tyler lockett here on the rich
eyes and showing again he's joining us
uh
on behalf of old spice a 10-year
initiative to help all young guys feel
confident in their own skin
and you can learn more by visiting old
spice's
social channels and there's also i'm
sure at td lock at 12
on twitter and instagram from seattle
seahawks i i know i've got a limited
time with you so if you don't mind
talking a little bit of football
and just the simple question of what
what what what the hell happened sunday
tyler what happened uh i think i think
buffalo just came to play
honestly i think they had a pretty good
game plan and
uh they were just able to take advantage
of us in a lot of
different areas but um for the most part
it just
allowed us to go look at the film kind
of understanding how they
how they hit us how they attacked us
starting to understand how other teams
have been attacking us
and how it applied into their game plan
and so i mean it really
helped us out just to be able to see how
they played a little bit differently
than how they played a lot of other
people or even what we expected
so when it when it comes down to it um
tyler
do you bury the film you know what i'm
saying i know you just said that
you can learn from it but is there some
sort of sense of you just
throw that one out um at all what what's
the
been the general sense so far for you
and yours no i mean i don't really think
you throw it out i think you just
remember it
but you you turn that pain into purpose
you know you turn the worst things into
purpose like you gotta
change the story and allow it to drive
you and allow you to be better and
overcome it
otherwise you know if you throw it away
you never really learn
from it and sometimes you end up
experiencing the same results
i think it's the same about life a lot
of times we do things that we're ashamed
of or we
or we do things to hurt other people and
we try to
just throw it away and just do better
but you gotta be able to turn that pain
and those mistakes and regrets the
purpose so that way
it heals you and it also drives you to
help other people
as they don't have to experience the
same thing so i think it's something
that'll help us out
so um i guess um before i let you go
uh looking back a few weeks ago um and
you know how i feel about you so there
is no disrespect when i ask this
question but
where were you uh on the buddha baker
interception where were you
tyler oh i was in the end zone i had a
route that i was running in the endzone
so i was in the end zone and after he
caught it
i saw dk running to chase him down so
i saw it i saw everything clear clearly
so you were you you you were not close
enough
even with the baker head start to to run
him down could you could you have if you
started from dk's position then
let's ask that question what do you
think uh
i don't know honestly i never really
tried that before
but i mean i i don't know
i would have to be in that position to
do it i i just wasn't in that position
at the time based off of my route he's
amazing isn't he
i mean we've already discussed it in
your last time here he has been
um quite a revelation your teammate
oh yeah he's been playing phenomenal and
i think it just says a lot
about him and just how he continuously
keeps his head down and just keeps
working
and you know doesn't let the praise get
to him doesn't let
all the um the high expectations get to
him he just goes out there and he sticks
to who he is and how he plays
hey tyler uh i appreciate you joining us
uh this initiative one more time
um i'll give you the floor and why it's
so important for people
to check it all out i think it's very
important just for everybody to check
out
the film black boys just because it
really allows you to see what life is
like for a lot of us as we grow up
how everybody thinks that we can only
make it through sports how we only think
we can make it through the entertainment
industry and
you don't really see too many people
that's out there being doctors or
lawyers or
other careers because that's all we're
taught and it's hard for us to be able
to make it because the education systems
and we don't get the same
type of opportunities as a lot of other
people
get as they grow up and it's all because
of the environment that we're in
and that has nothing to do with us it's
just that's what we were born into
but if we got the same opportunities and
we could also be able to make something
with our life as well so i think it's
really amazing that old spice is willing
to
do this 10-year commitment plan just to
be able to help people
graduate at a higher rate and i think
it's great being able to promote this
film black boys allowing people to
understand
what it's like on the when you look at
the foot on the other shoe
and a lot of people might not understand
until they actually see this film
and also i think that it'll be great
just to be able
to allow kids to thrive i think that's
one of the things we haven't been
allowing ourselves to do
because we put people in boxes of what
they could always do their whole life
but now
allowing kids to see that they could
thrive by being able to show them people
who have um been able to do a lot of
things in life that has to do
with other than sports and entertainment
it gives them hope
and opportunities that they could too be
successful in those
positions well tyler i've said this to
you before and the many times that
you've been kind enough to call into the
show i'm an admirer of your game but an
even big admirer of your heart soul and
mind
so um you know kudos to you for being
part of this
and i appreciate you taking some of your
day on on this tuesday to
to bring it to the audience here
thank you so much right back at you
that's uh that's tyler lockett
td lock at 12 on both twitter and
instagram and here again
is uh the documentary to which tyler
uh referred um it is produced in part
by malcolm jenkins we discussed it last
week when he came on this show
uh prior to um taking down the
bucks on sunday night a peacock original
black boys you can watch it right here
on peacock so crucial that you do hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here